[Music]
in both sides of the story news
submitted by Tokyo Drift transgender men
discussed the complexity of the question
on whether men really do have it easier
in life would you leave me if I was gay
but he needs to know no I would stay
with you more if you were gay because
then I could watch you having gay sex
okay you like that you should know this
about me that's real love right there
that's time well I get some more from a
selfish Jessica thing yeah would you
leave me if I was gay because there's
only dicks and that is so straight she
likes a lot of big the straightest
straight person I like a lot of [ __ ] so
straight that I think I might be a gay
man deep inside wow that's true I'm
lesbian alright so I thought this piece
was so [ __ ] interesting yeah I love
that this is yeah cuz part reddit as
well this is from the Washington Post
and it was this journalist she
interviewed for transgender men which
means they were born a woman and then
they converted it yeah they transitioned
to envision sword as a converted
transitioned into a man a lot of them
transition like for over 10 years ready
hmm someone like 2006 a lot of the
people in this article like look
straight up like macho dudes like you I
would never be able to tell I can work
at Home Depot or something they were
women yeah but you could see like the
scars from the breast reduction and
things like that but very passing so
there's four people right hopefully
we'll get to all four but we'll start
with Tristan who's 50 years old
he's a professor of Gender Studies at
Cal California state universities dan
nice lips
San Luis Obispo stanislavski's I'm
[ __ ] heard of that one I just thought
Spanish like [ __ ] gay throw me he's
so boring dude
all right so this is what it looks like
that does not look like a chick at all
to me looks like a dude I feel kind of
attracted oh well not necessarily to
that guy but I feel a little bit sad for
the men that are transitioning to women
because I feel like they have a much
harder time for sure in some anti guys
yeah hi guys hi guys are like fragile
bone actor and stuff but for a lot of
the women all they have to do is take
testosterone and then like after you
know a few years or whatever like they
can look more like men's apples to do
testosterone is powerful [ __ ] yeah yeah
so with with Tristan here he
transitioned back in 2008 and so he was
saying that life doesn't get easier as
an african-american male because usually
for african-americans and Latino
Americans they grow up as boys being
taught that they had to deal with with
their emotions and everything at an
earlier age and so we had to learn so he
had to learn how to stay alive in his
new body and regain retained some
dignity well-being didn't mean like hops
because for him before which he would
get stopped when he was a woman you get
stopped and he would get away with it
like if he was stuck for an actual
violation for speeding he would just get
off and then um at one point even had
like an in-depth conversation with one
of the cops but then after transitioning
now the the first two questions that
he's being asked is do you have any
weapons in the car
and are you on parole probation right so
that's as a as a man he's treated worse
but but as a black woman he was still
treated better yeah then uh then uh then
as a black man exactly and there's even
an incident when he called like the fire
department or the police because someone
ran into his neighbor's at home right so
he called the police and then when the
police came they treated him like the
get down on the ground and that's never
happened to him as a black woman so they
were like wow this [ __ ] is real and I
think that's one thing that girls forget
females forget that men are always
viewed as threats yeah well even if you
did nothing wrong because you know
statistically guys are the main
criminals in this world even if it's
like a domestic abuse case yeah let's
say me and Geo there's like a loud fight
the neighbors call the cops they're
gonna assume they're gonna assume that
I'm beating Sheila's ass even though
she's way taller than me like a bunch of
cuts and bruises and she has none they
still might they still might be my rehab
so now he says that he avoids ever
calling the cops because it's just gonna
end up bad so he's like if I was jogging
somewhere and I run a crop like I come
across a dead body I'm gonna keep
running I'm not gonna call the cops
because now him his life as a black man
is very difficult and it he's saying
that it's not only humiliating but it
creates anxiety on a daily basis before
he used to feel safe going up to a cop
but now does he regret a decision he was
gonna say does he think it's like he
doesn't regret this decision but now
he's actually changed like the way he
dresses and like the way he couldn't
like presents himself because before
like even though he likes urban and
vetted aesthetics
he stopped wearing hoodies he traded his
baggy jeans and oversized jerseys for
colorful skull cut and colorful skull
caps for clothes fitting jeans khakis
and sweaters and so he's just saying
like you know the less visible I am the
better my chances of surviving I think
the biggest iOpener for me was a lot of
these when when when I guess when they
were women a lot of them were like
feminist activists was it one of them
okay so I guess what I read was the
feminist activist yeah yeah when they
became a man they were just debunking
their own thoughts on a lot of things
interesting yeah so this is Xander
this is who Joe is talking about oh yeah
he looks like someone's Theo he looks
like a like a barbecue pit master
absolutely dude you don't see he works
at West Coast Customs yeah it looks like
he could weld more like more than a man
than me yeah he makes me feel like a
woman
yeah like if I like did you ever like
that guy can you be as my for sure sure
if we were in jail he would make me his
[ __ ] he's 52 years old he's a Coast
Guard Coast Guard veteran he works at
Naval Medical Center San Diego as a
clinical social worker case manager he's
the editor of anthologies about
transgender men and he started
transitioning back in 2005 so like joe
said before he was an active activist
I'm sorry he was a very outspoken
radical lesbian feminist who used to be
before you transition and so he would
speak up often and loudly and with
confidence and he was encouraged to
speak up and he was even given awards
for his efforts but when he speaks up
now he's often given the direct or
indirect message of the fact that he's
mansplaining
and it turned around like I used to be a
wolf like 30 years [ __ ] yeah and
then no or like so taking up too much
space or asserting his well his white
male heterosexual privilege even though
he's a first-generation mexican-american
and transgender man you have to navigate
with words like very carefully I refuse
I mean yeah but you still do but you
start yeah yeah I think white guys have
it the worst actually yeah you can read
the room at that attack I think that's
what separates it I see em like white
guys have to watch their words the most
out of everyone yeah and then it just
goes down like I think there's like
oppression Awards of whoever was the
most oppression they could say the most
and now I guess this man feels like he
is less oppressed because he's a man
so it's like weird for him to realize
like oh I can't even actually sale these
things that I used to feel comfortable
saving because now I'm a man so I'm like
less on the list and now I have to be
quiet I can't mansplain so that's
interesting to be like on both sides of
exactly to experience both sides I
wonder how his friends feel about that
cuz I assume that he should have like a
lot of friends that were also in the
same kind of circles and groups and
thought very similarly and I wonder if
their opinion changed or felt weird
knowing that it's the same person well
you know what's interesting
the next person we talk about does talk
about how his friend reacted to his
transition yeah so this guy here his
name is Chris 49 years old transitions
and his mid-20s and this is what he
looks like he's Chris who looks manly
too it was George Clooney Berg crazy
so for Chris he said oh so he's an
advertising creative director public
speaker and author of a memoir called
balls
it takes some to get some I like that
dude no kidding if you go through that
surgery bro you got balls man holy [ __ ]
and you're dedicated yeah yeah it's a
dedication you are not an imposter if
you believe what you're saying yes yeah
so he's saying that you began his
transition at age 26 and a lot of
socialization came from the guys at work
so as a woman he'd walk down the hall
and bump into some of his female
co-workers and they'd say hey what's up
and I'd say oh I just got out of this
client meeting bubbeleh and like really
get into it but then as a guy he bumped
into a guy in the hall and he would say
what's up and then he'd go into this
story and then by the time he realized
like he's already down the hall like the
other guy and then so he was like well
that's kind of [ __ ] rude women are
chatty
yeah women are chatty and he had to get
used to it he had to get used to guys
not being attached go like what's up bro
and then they keep walking I don't give
a [ __ ] about your life dude I gotta go
damn that's true unless we go how was
your weekend yeah but even that means I
went fishing and I had a burger
talking too much roughly the music yeah
I had a barber and I went fishing cool
later
Oh words a good burger at al-khawaja
check it out yeah and then you look on
your phone and you go Monday burger get
it you want to go get this burger and
then the other guy goes [ __ ] yeah and
then you go eat burgers
that's a good burger he was saying like
when you're socially transitioning you
want to blend in and not stand out so
it's uncomfortable when little reminders
pop up that you're not like everybody
else so for example he was also expected
to know everything about sports and like
he watches sports but he's not like
super deep into sports like a lot of
guys and he remembers the first time he
was out at a wedding as a groomsman it
was maybe about three years into his
transition that all the guys lined up
for a photo and one of them shouted
high-school-football pose and then
everyone just dropped down and squatted
like on the offense line offensive line
and he was like what the hell is going
on like I've never played like I don't
know what the [ __ ] for if a guy was
transitioning into a woman and all the
girls were like sorta squad in like the
bend and snap or whatever and then you
know like the guy would be like wait
what you know like what's the bend and
snap
oh yeah so then he was saying that he
noticed that hormones made him become
more impatient so he had a lot of female
friends and one of the qualities that
they really loved about him was like he
was a great listener but after being on
testosterone they told him that his
listening skills weren't what they used
to be so one example is that he was
driving with one of his friends and he
asked her like hey is your sister
meeting us up for dinner and then ten
minutes later she was still talking and
he still had no idea whether or not she
was coming so he ended up just snapping
and said is she coming or not and then
that's when the friend was like you know
I used to like hearing all the backstory
and had to get around to the answer and
a lot of us have noticed that you have
become very impatient lately and we
think of that damn testosterone
testosterone does that
he's able to understand like the the way
men are in such a way that I can't ever
like can you imagine being in a man's
mind like all you have to do is take
some testosterone really like well I
think we're more complicated than no
that's the thing about us man so that
was like gee I'm super complicating that
I'm just laying at home I'm just like no
I'm pretty satisfied with just these
three things I'm gonna hamburger and a
beer right here yeah have you ever had
that moment like am i deep yeah and then
it like just spaces out and nowhere
right I don't think I'm Oh women feel
deep as hell I know you're holding your
hand you're clutching your elbows like a
woman right now I love it I just want to
sit on a couch somewhere yeah I like
that too just tell the [ __ ] I wish I had
a gin and tonic a man who's just talked
about earlier because she's really into
that [ __ ] and and I wish I was this
[ __ ] chilling you know it means is
that it's not a chill just now I'm like
I like you say uncomfortable seating
maybe the lights a little lower
yeah let me keep the woman chatter to a
minimum yeah and a little bit of music
I'm deep I study pyramids and [ __ ] like
a professor I think I'm deep I studied
career is this [ __ ] I mean who does it
the stupid ones reading about the last
person you should check out that article
it's actually really fascinating
especially if you're a woman you don't
know what the experience is like for a
man like me when I was reading this
all's like in your face girls you think
life is easier being a male well in a
lot of ways it is but there are little
nuances that we as females don't pay
attention to or don't even think about
how do you guys for us like the same
thing is I don't think life is easy for
a woman I think life is [ __ ] hard but
I don't look at any group and think you
got it good I think rich people have
their own [ __ ] problems everybody
else well it's not as bad as poor people
but still
I think rich people have it worse
important people you know why because
Casey and I were at the beach recently
and like we were just sitting down
talking and this really rich lady she
comes like she passes behind us because
we were sitting like by the boardwalk
thing and she was talking crazy but you
could tell she was like really well off
because this [ __ ] that she was wearing
that's true talking to herself and I
thought she had like an earpiece or
something but it's kind of like blue
Jasmine did you ever see that movie hmm
you should watch it it's it's it
reminded me of that she's just crazy I
know she's rich she's just she went to
Beverly Hills good work crazy
I salute Jasmine talks about that Sookie
this is rich lady that her husband ends
up getting locked up and she's them
money anymore she goes crazy because
she's broke oh I saw a rich lady in a
Rolls Royce in West LA and then she was
picking her nose and eating it like
aggressively yeah with both of her
fingers she she was at a stoplight and
she was like I saw a rich lady in a
Bentley hit a homeless guy and then she
was like [ __ ] I just got it cleaned are
you [ __ ] [ __ ] me
wait her she had the table dip yeah corn
Jesus crazy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]